if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've done before what is
the first thing you want them watching
and why
that's a great question and i have done
thousands of interviews and i've never
been asked that um
probably
barry monday
is there a reason
if you've ever seen that you probably
haven't because that's probably the
closest to
me i don't feel like i need to prove my
skill set i mean i could say something
like angels in america or
fargo or little children or you know
horror stuff i guess but
i feel like that's my
i'd want someone to laugh
you know so i'd probably give them
something and i haven't done a ton of
comedy uh but that that that for me i'd
probably give them that you know just to
go wait that's that's you like yeah yeah
that's actually me all this other stuff
so right yeah you you also haven't done
a lot of sci-fi so when roland said to
you do you want to do this were you like
uh yes yeah yeah for sure yeah no no i
really wanted to do it i i had not done
a lot of sci-fi and i loved sci-fi so
for me i was um
it's a you know as as you know i like i
like to do a lot of different genres and
i i don't work in this
space
pun intended like almost at all so um
but i love it i love sci-fi movies so
for me i was like a kid in a candy store
it was great
you've worked with roland before uh what
does he actually what what do you think
might surprise fans of roland emmerich
about the way he works on a set
that he's very
it's he's a very relaxed focus
it's not even when he's stressed it's
very direct and very easy probably very
german
you know stop doesn't look good stop do
it over
it doesn't what do you do it you know
but it's but it's never
there's it's always with
care and ease that'll be this they'll be
that and you know it's it's it's it and
it's not
it's very passionate and very focused
but it's not you kind of imagine a
disaster movie someone like yes
explosions here we go the moon's coming
and just going crazy and he's just the
complete opposite it's just it's it'll
be this and then these scary things come
at you and yeah no it's really bizarre
you know it's very very chill so i think
that was that's for me probably the
biggest difference of what you'd expect
from these
massive epic disaster movies
uh what do you think it is about people
love like end of the world tv shows end
of the world movies destruction uh what
is it about that genre that people keep
coming back to it
because i think i think there's all
there's always a kernel of us like just
a little piece of us inside that kind of
feels like
god what if it did all end like what
what there is something i don't think
people are necessarily fatalistic but
you know it's twofold i think you can go
see a movie and it's a real escape and
you can walk out and go
well things are stressful to me but it's
not nearly that bad
so maybe it makes you feel better but
also there's a there's a controlled i'll
give it to you like this
a lot of psychologists think that horror
movies can be good for teenagers because
there's a release there's tension and
there's a built-in release of the scare
and that actually makes them get over
their fears you see something very scary
and then there's a release and it's gone
and i think there's a similar thing with
disaster movies because a lot of us
worry about
the disaster or environmental issues or
what's going to happen or uh life is
stressful but a disaster movie gives you
that release
and and that escape but usually there's
a human elephant that elephant a human
element that is also a human elephant
that's a whole different movie there's a
human element that always makes you care
about there's usually a happy ending
right the world's usually saved and i
think that with the exception of don't
look up every other movie
um
you know spoiler alert you know usually
ends in a positive way and i think that
makes people walk out feeling like wow
for for an hour and a half i felt really
stressed in that past 15 minutes now i
feel good and i think i think there's
actually something psychological if i
really break it down
i am a big fan of james wan and i am
incredibly looking forward to a certain
sequel called aquaman two um and i just
have to ask you what what can you tease
about it uh because i cannot wait
if you have an ocean master figure
behind you i will give you every spoiler
[Laughter]
now you know next time you interview me
show me an ocean master
i meant
but what the thing is though like with
the first film you really don't know if
audiences are going to respond to it
because it's so different you know um
and but what was it like actually making
the sequel because you know audiences
loved the first one yeah so you take
those things that you think people
responded to even if it was
oh my god can you believe they did that
like yeah we did that now we're gonna do
more of that so um
yeah i i think we found our niche you
know i think dc has found their way to
understand where each movie can fit even
in a
even in a multiverse which is so
overused now
as a term um but i think we
you know clearly the movie went beyond a
fanboy
uh demographic right because it made
whatever billion dollars right so the so
that that affords you a freedom of like
you know what let's let's keep it fun
let's make it fun and there's we still
have our layers of environmental issues
we've got a great
relationships in the movies some
fantastic action sequences so we push
all the the fighting and the stunts as
we've used crazy techniques between us
and flash that never been used before so
all these new vfx techniques that we're
using um and then storyline is is
you know obviously not gonna get into
that but james loves to pick and choose
from
from his own mind and comics and how we
bring in certain elements you know and
and those little moments that that
that even i don't know pick one in the
gladiator sequence like
there's an octopus playing drums now
comic book nerds will go yeah well it's
toppo like come on guys like that's
that's who it is so those little moments
there'll be a lot more of that stuff for
sure
yeah also james is on a roll he is just
such a talented filmmaker
now he's terrible
got it on that note i gotta go all right
listen
thank you so much for your time and i've
lesson learned for the next time we
speak there you go